I'm pleased to introduce Peggy Orenstein in addition to being a best selling
author.
She's been named one of the 40 women who changed the media business in the past
40 years by the Columbia Journalism Review.
Her last few books have focused on topics related to her growing daughter or
relevant to them.
And this book continues in that tradition.
As the father of a teenage girl,
I found the topic both interesting and concerning.
Even though I started the book with my daughter in mind along the way,
it gave me insights,
relevance,
relevance to both of my children.
And I'm sure you'll find it in cycle too.
Please join me in giving a warm welcome to Peggy Orenstein.
Oh Yeah,
look,
I've got a microphone on me.
Um,
this is interesting because I have yet to do an event just to where there are
more than three men present.
So this is sort of cool.
I wondered about this coming to Google because I kind of figured it was a little
bit more of a guy place to work off the deck might be a stereotype and I
apologize if that's true,
but um,
but that was a,
I was,
I was excited about that.
So I wanted to talk a little bit about this book and how I came to do it and um,
some of what I've found and then I thought we could just chat if that works for
you guys.
So,
um,
I came to this book really I,
my previous book had been called Cinderella it my daughter.
And that was looking at the ways that the culture was telling girls from the
very youngest ages that how they looked was more important than who they were.
And I was looking at that through a kind of pop cultural lens and I was looking
at it partly because I'm a mother myself and I have a 12 now,
12 and a half year old daughter.
Um,
and after I finished that book,
I was going around and I was starting to hear some stories that were,
that were really concerning me about the hookup culture and about sexting and
about,
um,
binge drinking.
And my first response was to kind of go,
Ooh,
my child photo,
I don't have to hear this.
I don't want to hear this yet.
Parenting from ignorance and fear generally not the best idea.
So I started sort of digging into it and,
and what I wanted to look at was we had,
we're having this umbrella conversation in this culture right now that's been
going on for several years about assault on campus.
And it's a really,
really,
really important topic.
But consent
some really low bar for a sexual experience,
you know,
like I was not assaulted is a really low bar for a sexual experience.
And so I became really interested in looking at what was going on in young
women's lives after.
Yes.
And what had changed,
what hadn't,
how they,
whether they felt more in control,
if their experience,
whether they were more able to create something that was satisfying them,
whether they were more able to articulate their wants,
needs and desires and previous generations and whether some of the dynamics that
were happening in those relationships were feeding into the culture that was
surfacing around coercive sex and assault.
So I decided to,
um,
talk to young women who were between the ages of 15 and 20,
because that's sort of when girls are becoming sexually active.
And I talked to girls who were,
uh,
they,
they spend a pretty broad ethnic demographic.
Um,
but they were all middle class.
They were all in high school,
either going to college or already in college.
And I particularly chose that demographic because I wanted to talk to girls that
we think of as having opportunity and the kind of girls that,
you know,
we think of as being the beneficiaries of the feminist movement.
Because if those girls who were,
I mean the girls I talked to,
they were,
if I had been interviewing them about their education,
their aspirations,
their professional dreams,
I would've walked away.
So impressed.
And if these girls who were leaning in all over the place,
you know,
we're toppling in their personal lives,
I felt that we couldn't really deny that there were issues that we needed to
address.
And what I found with them was that while today's young women felt entitled to
engage in sexual activity,
they didn't necessarily feel entitled to enjoy it.
So as one young woman I talked to who was a sophomore and Ivy League school said
to me,
you know,
I come from generations of strong women and my grandmother was a firecracker and
my mother super strong and my sister and I are really loud and that's our
feminine power.
And then she proceeded to articulate a kind of series of
hookups that were kind of demeaning,
depersonalized,
not very pleasurable.
And she said,
you know,
I think,
I think we girls are socialized to be deferential and not express our once.
And I said,
wait five minutes ago,
you told me that you were a really strong woman.
And she kind of hemmed and hawed and she said,
yeah,
you know,
I don't think anybody ever told me that that strong woman image applied to sex.
And I began to think about this disconnect between how we talk about sex in the
culture and how we see sex all around us and how the landscape is littered with
female body parts.
He used to sell everything that we can possibly think of and the complete dearth
of honest conversation,
frank conversation,
real authentic conversation that we have with young women and young men,
but particularly young women,
um,
about sex.
And the whole idea of where the,
my previous book led me to this book or saying girls used to,
you know,
talk about pretty and how it was more important to be pretty than to be anything
else that had morphed into hot and girls were sold hot,
which is a,
you know,
a really narrow,
superficial,
commercialized idea of what's sexy and what's attractive.
That tells them over and over that how their bodies look to someone else is more
important than how those bodies feel to themselves and their salt.
That in a way that whereas I think parents who are gen x parents or who are baby
boom parents,
women that age would have pushed back against that is self objectification or
sexualization for today's young women that's sold as a source of empowerment and
self confidence and often as the most important,
um,
uh,
source of self confidence and power.
So it becomes much more complicated for those girls,
for instances.
One Young Woman that I was talking to said she showed me a picture of herself.
Yeah.
And she was,
um,
going to a party and she had the requisite crop top and little skirt and high
heels.
And she said,
you know,
I'm proud of my body and I never feel more liberated than when I'm wearing
skimpy clothing.
And I said,
okay.
And we talked about it a little more and she said,
and a few minutes later,
she said that a year previous she wouldn't have worn that same outfit because
she was 25 pounds heavier.
And as she put it,
some Jerky boys would have called me the fat girl and that would be bad for my
mental health.
So then,
you know,
I felt we needed to have a discussion and have a discussion with young girls
about who gets to be proud of which bodies under what circumstances and how
liberating that idea of hot really is.
If humiliation and judgment look just around the corner.
And what we know in the culture of hot is that self sexualization affects girls
cognitively,
psychologically,
and in a real bait and switch.
It affects them sexually.
Girls who self sexualized,
I actually report less power in the bedroom,
less self satis,
less satisfaction,
um,
less control over their experiences.
So there's this way that I felt like,
okay,
if the opposite were true,
if this was truly creating a more powerful situation for girls in the workplace,
in education,
in their sex lives,
I'd have to say,
all right,
I'm just fusty and old and it's time for me to shuffle off.
You know?
But
it seemed quite apparent to me that the confidence was coming out with the
clothes coming off with the clothes and whether we were talking about porn,
whether we were talking about pap,
whether we're talking about fashion,
what girls were learning was that pleasing others was more important than their
own pleasure.
That being desirable was more important than understanding their desire.
That appearing sexy was more important than understanding their own sexuality.
And one of the things that I talk about in the book is,
um,
the way that we need to,
as adults change the way that we talk about sex with kids and broaden our
definition of sex beyond virginity and beyond intercourse.
Because when we talk about sex as being intercourse,
we are,
and,
and in fact,
the rates of intercourse among kids have not changed.
They get,
they're sexually active at the same age as they were 20 years ago,
and they're sexually active at the same rates,
however that denies and diminishes and marginalizes the other forms of sexual
activity that they're taking that are taking place,
particularly oral sex.
And it makes it so that those are not subject to the same rules about consent,
coercion,
responsibility and respect.
It makes it into not sex.
So particularly were oral sex work was concerned?
Yeah,
I heard so many stories about girls having one,
you know,
oral sex.
And when I say that,
I mean female on male because male and female was a whole different situation
for girls.
But female on male,
they would describe as not sex.
They would describe as no big deal.
And they engaged in it for a lot of reasons.
It was,
um,
to please a partner to,
uh,
gain popularity to,
um,
feel a sense of power to feel desirable,
uh,
because they wanted an evening to end and they wanted a guy to go away and they
didn't know how else to make them go away.
Um,
but it was rarely something that was in their own bodies.
And after awhile I started saying to girls,
because I got no sort of frustrated by hearing all these stories of this one way
situation.
What if every time you were alone with a guy,
he asked you to go to the kitchen and get them a glass of water and he never
offered to get you a glass of water?
Or if he did,
it was kind of like,
you want me to,
you know,
get you a glass of water.
No,
really begrudging when you would never stand for it.
And they would say,
they would laugh and they'd say,
well,
when you put it that way,
yeah.
And I said,
well,
you know,
maybe you need to put it that way.
Maybe do we need to think about why for you it's more insulting to think about
getting somebody a glass of water then performing a nonreciprocal sex act and it
just about girls getting theirs.
But I became very intrigued with this idea of what Sarah Mclachlan,
who's a researcher at the University of Michigan calls intimate justice.
And just like when we talk about,
you know,
who does the dishes in your home is partly a political act as well as a personal
accommodation.
Sex has those dynamics too.
And it can bring up similar ideas about equality,
economic disparity,
mental health,
violence.
And we need to ask,
when we talk about girls and sex,
who gets to engage in an experience,
who's entitled to enjoy it?
Who's the primary beneficiary of that experience and how each partner defines
good enough.
And those are really thorny ideas to explore for adult women I think.
But when we're talking about girls early formative experience that's going to be
following them through their lives.
You know,
I just,
I don't want girls early experiences to be something that they have to get over.
And that was something that I was just hearing way too much.
So as part of that intimate justice,
we set girls up to expect inequality and their sexual relationships.
And I call that the,
um,
psychological clutter reductor me that we engage in.
So when baby girls in baby boys are born,
we tend to name all of our baby boy's body parts.
So at least we'll say like there's your pee pee,
something like that,
you know.
But with girls we tend to go from naval to knees and we just don't name that
great void and there's no better way to make something unspeakable the not to
name it.
Then girls go into their puberty education classes and they learned that boys
have erections and ejaculations and girls have periods and unwanted pregnancy,
which are not the same thing.
And we only see that sort of internal diagram.
Um,
you know,
that looks like a steer head of,
of girls and it grays out between the legs.
So we never hear the word Volvo,
we never hear the word cliteracy.
And not surprisingly,
fewer than half of girls ages 14 to 17 have ever masturbated.
And then they go into their partner and interactions and we somehow expect that
magically they're going to be able to articulate their wants,
their needs,
their desires,
their limits,
and have those respected,
we think that they're going to be able to think they have a voice.
We think that they're going to be able to advocate for an equal relationship.
And it's really just not that realistic.
And so again,
you know,
I wanted to talk about that idea of virginity and I wanted to talk about that
idea,
the idea of satisfaction.
Because one thing that we know is that we think of satisfaction as being one
kind of monolithic idea and that we know how to find it.
But in fact,
young women and young men define satisfaction very differently.
So young women are more likely than young men to define,
to measure their satisfaction by their partners pleasure.
So they'll say if he had a good time,
I had a good time.
Whereas young men are more likely to measure their satisfaction by their own
pleasure.
So if I had a good time,
I had a good time.
What's interesting is that that dynamic remains the same for girls when they're
in same sex relationships.
So that's when we sort of see an interesting transformation that in same sex
liaisons,
girls tend to be orgasmic at the same rate as heterosexual men.
Also really interesting.
And back to the point of virginity or I don't know,
actually,
let me skip back a second before we get to that.
Um,
one of the things that gay and lesbian girls would say,
oh gay and bisexual girls would say to me is that when they were with other
women,
other girls that they felt that they could get off the script and they use
several of them use that word script.
Um,
which you know,
is the cultural script,
the media script,
the porn script,
every script,
the sex education script.
And that when they got off that script,
they were free to create an experience that worked for them.
And that wasn't dictated by something outside of themselves.
And it was a more creative act.
And that really stuck with me is something that I think that we can learn from.
Um,
even if we're in a other sex liaisons.
the other piece of that was,
uh,
when I was talking earlier about virginity,
when we continually talk about sex and virginity as intercourse,
not because intercourse is no big deal.
Of course it's a big deal,
but it's not the only big deal.
And it also marginalizes,
and it completely ignores the experience of lesbian and bisexual girls.
And so I asked a young woman,
how did you know that you weren't a virgin anymore when you've never had
heterosexual intercourse?
I get to make this joke here.
This is so great.
She said,
I had to Google it.
Guess what?
Google didn't know,
guys get on it.
So she said,
there was no answer.
And uh,
I said,
well,
what is your side?
And she sort of hemmed and she hard for a while and she said,
you know,
I think I stopped being a virgin when I had my first orgasm with a partner.
And I thought,
just for a second,
what if that was the definition,
how that would shift or whole conception of sexuality.
And it's this idea that sexuality,
especially for young people,
should be this pool of experiences that is about warmth and closeness and
affection and sensation and communication and pleasure,
not this race to a goal.
And,
you know,
I like to say when I talk to young people who's really more experienced,
the person who spends three hours kissing their partner and the experimenting
with these ideas of erotic tension and communication and sensation or the person
who gets wasted hooks up with a random and tries to dump their virginity before
they get to college.
So it's just a way to sort of,
you know,
think about how to reframe this.
And
I'm starting to decide how much I want to talk and how much I want to let the
to,
to let you guys ask.
I mean,
I,
I talk a lot about the,
the hookup culture and what has changed in recent years on the end.
You know,
young people did not invent casual sex.
Right?
I heard that.
Um,
you know,
please.
But what has changed is the idea that co that sex arise,
arises out of,
um,
I mean,
uh,
proceeds rather than a rises out of intimacy.
And that that's the norm.
And that was true in colleges.
And it was because of me becoming more true in high school so that whether young
women,
um,
wanted to be part of hookup culture or wanted to opt out of cook up culture or
wanted to go in and out,
or however they wanted to do what they had to,
um,
define themselves in their relationships,
in their sexuality and relationship to that culture.
And some young women were really into it.
Um,
some girls would come in and sit down and say,
I am so sick of women being portrayed as victims of the hookup culture.
I'm a participant.
I want to be here.
You know,
this serves me.
I don't want a boyfriend right now.
I don't have time for a boyfriend right now.
I want to focus on school.
I want to focus on my friends and I still want to have a sex life.
And this is how I do it.
Other women found it,
you know,
unhygienic and just not something that they wanted to purchase date,
but they all had to do that.
And what became interesting to me was not thinking about hookups,
good or hookups,
bad relationships,
good or relationships bad.
I'm not prescriptive that way.
That's not my job.
But what I did want to talk about with girls and what I did want them to know
was what they were likely and probably we're not likely to get out of a
situation.
So to know that if you're going to do,
if you're going to go out and hook up,
and hookups of course are not just lubricated by alcohol,
they are dependent on it.
Um,
in order to create what a sociologist at Occidental told me was called
compulsory carelessness.
So trying to,
you know,
anesta size,
you're against itself against feelings so that you can go into the sexual
liaisons.
And she said,
actually her interview subjects talk about I'm sober sex.
Like it was an amazing Unicorn.
Um,
but so going into a hookup,
you'll probably get an adrenaline rush.
You'll probably get,
um,
a sense of conquest,
a war story.
Um,
you'll probably feel desirable for a short period of time.
You'll get a warm body.
You might have some fun.
What you probably won't get out of hookups is a good sex or the tools that you
need in order to practice good sex or create intimacy.
So my hope was by surfacing that and surfacing how girls talked about hookups
was to allow them to look at what the realities were of their choices and then
make the choice from an informed place.
I'm not telling them how to make it,
but this is what they need to know.
So
at the end of the book,
I see I end in a coed classroom and I do that on purpose because I really wanted
to stop in a place where boys and girls were working out these issues together
because I do have great belief that teenagers are thoughtful,
they are eager,
they're interested,
and they're capable of working out their ethics,
their values and learning to,
you know,
treat people with ethics and respect.
And in part of that,
and looking at that section of the book,
I also looked at other countries and one of the things that was most interesting
to me was comparing the experience of Dutch teenagers to American teenagers.
And I looked at research that showed how a Dutch college girls and American
college girls spoke about their early sexual experiences.
So these were demographically very similar groups
on every measure.
Yeah.
The Dutch girls,
whether it was fewer negative consequences like pregnancy disease,
um,
regret or enhanced positive consequences like,
okay.
You know,
knowing your partner,
preparing responsibly,
enjoying the experience,
uh,
having a positive body image.
Every single measure,
the Dutch girls came out way ahead.
They embodied everything that we hope for for our girls.
So what was different?
Well,
in Dutch culture,
teachers,
doctors and parents talk explicitly about sex from the time kids are young,
not in a,
you know,
in an age appropriate way,
obviously.
Um,
and what was particularly different was parents that while parents,
American parents and Dutch parents were no less,
we're no different in their comfort levels.
And talking about sex,
American parents spoke exclusively about risk and disease and Dutch parents
talked about balancing responsibility and joy.
And I'll tell you that.
Thinking about that as a parent really made a big difference to me because I
think that before I would have reflexively said,
you know,
I've talked to my daughter about contraception,
I've talked to my daughter about disease protection,
I've talked to my daughter because I'm really modern.
I've talked to her about consent,
but,
and then I would have thought,
good job,
Peggy job is done.
Now I know that that's not true.
And there's a whole other job that I have to figure out how to do.
And that's important for boys as well.
And one of the,
I'll tell you that one of the most meaningful moments in
the classroom that I was in was when a young boy in high school,
boy raised his hand and they were talking about some meeting.
He said,
you know that baseball metaphor for sex and baseball,
there's winners and there's losers.
So who's supposed to be the loser and sex?
And I thought,
you know,
Bingo,
like that was just a small revelation.
But that boy and making that switch,
we'll go more into his partnerships as a partner rather than as an adversary
trying to score.
And actually I don't even think the girls in that metaphor or the opposite team.
I think the girls might be the field.
Right?
It's not even that good.
So you know,
thinking about how to replace that.
I have,
and I'll,
and I'll end on this because it's my favorite thing in the world.
You guys know l Vernaccia.
Do you know who he is?
He is.
He did a Ted talk.
He is a sex educator and in Pennsylvania and he advocates replacing the base.
And if you can do one thing with your kids,
this is,
this is it replacing the baseball metaphor with the pizza metaphor.
And here's why.
When we go out to pizza,
we have a shared experience.
First we decide together you want to have pizza?
Yeah,
pizza.
Then we go to the pizza place and we order a pie and we negotiate.
We talk about like maybe I like mushrooms and you like Pepperoni.
And so maybe we'll go halfsies or maybe,
um,
we'll have mushrooms this time and Pepperoni next time.
Or maybe if you keep insisting on Pepperoni and I keep kosher,
I'm not going to go out to pizza with you anymore.
Or you know,
it's,
it's a kind of endless metaphor,
but it is all about having an experience that's shared.
Everybody's invested in one another's pleasure.
You would never want to go out to pizza and have your,
you're not care if your partner didn't like the pizza you were having.
You want them to like the pizza.
You want to have an enjoyable experience.
You want to be communicating.
And it's,
you know,
you can see you can,
you can take that metaphor in all different directions,
but it's so far superior and thinking about how we can talk to our kids and
raise them so that they can think about their sexuality in terms of intimate
justice and so that they can think about engaging ethically,
responsibly,
respectfully and joyfully.
Whether the liaisons lasts for 10 minutes or whether they last for 10 years.
So I will stop there and I'd be happy to take any questions.
Probably not the discussion you think you're going to have in the middle of a
workday.
Right.
I appreciate that you came.
Anybody have any,
any thoughts?
Yeah,
so the question I have is about the research that compares the Netherlands and
the United States.
Is there research that compares to the Netherlands to the best state in the u s
because it seems like it's such a small country and all the people are very
similar,
whereas us is huge and very diverse.
Right?
So I feel like it's maybe not a very fair comparison.
Well,
here's why.
It was a fair comparison because it wasn't comparing the demographic to a broad
swath of the United States.
It was comparing two sets of girls who were in college who were the same age,
who were the same ethnic background and who were the same,
um,
uh,
largely the same religious background and the same,
economic background.
So it was comparing,
it wasn't comparing Dutch girls to the broad swath of American society.
It was comparing the demographic that I was particularly interested in.
To the demographic I was particularly interested in.
But in terms of,
um,
states,
you know,
yeah,
there's huge diverse,
I mean,
the truth is that only 23 states in our country mandate sex education and only
13 mandate that it'd be medically accurate.
I know,
I mean it's,
it's very sad.
And one of them I'm from,
I live in California and one of them is supposed to be mine,
but it wasn't until last summer that the city of Clovis,
uh,
was found in violation of that because they were running films,
um,
in their sex ed class that compared a sexually active unmarried woman to a dirty
old shoe.
Um,
and had the kids chanting,
I can't remember exactly what they were saying.
No,
but they were cheating teaching them antigay slogans to champion school in
public school.
Yup.
Thank you.
[inaudible] you know,
I'll say one other thing about the Netherlands too,
that's a sort of broader idea about them.
But the one thing that also really struck me as a parent was Amy [inaudible] who
wrote a book called not under my roof and also compared the Netherlands to
Americans.
She found some really interesting things and one of them was that we expect
American teenagers to grow up by creating a rift with their parents that we
expect,
particularly girls,
we expect them to be to present as the good girl at home and to lie either
overtly or blood or by omission about what they're doing outside of the home.
And I certainly saw that with the girls I talked to who are always saying things
like,
Ugh,
my father thinks I'm a virgin or my mother.
It has no idea what I'm doing.
Or You know,
and in Holland they're expected to these matters in the family.
They're expected to grow up in an interdependent way with the family.
And parents use that as a way to continue to exert a kind of soft control over
the kids so that they can reiterate ideas about safety,
ideas about values,
ideas about respect.
And when I thought about that,
I thought,
oh my gosh,
I don't want my daughter to have to grow up by lying to me.
I want her to,
I want to be on her team.
Well at the same time,
I also realized that,
um,
that can be hard to do when you're the parent,
especially in our culture.
And so I really advocate also building the team.
Here's a good bit,
this baseball metaphor works.
Build the team.
Um,
and,
and I've been that person where I,
I,
you know,
I have a friend whose daughter was becoming thinking about becoming a,
having intercourse when she was 16.
And she asked me though,
the mother asked me to go out and have a conversation with the girl and like
everybody,
I wanted to fall through the floor.
I'm no different.
Um,
but I said,
look,
um,
let's talk about this.
I know you're thinking about this.
Let's talk about contraception.
Let's talk about disease protection.
Let's talk about consent.
And I'm going to ask you some questions.
You don't have to answer them,
but I want you to think about them.
Have you ever masturbated?
Have you had an orgasm on your own?
Have you had an orgasm with your partner?
Can you tell this partner what you like and don't like?
Can you tell him no.
When you're ready to stop and have him respect that.
Are you able to communicate with him around these issues?
And if you answer no to those questions,
what is it that you want out of this experience?
What is it that you want for you?
Why are you,
why are you doing this?
And she didn't really answer.
She just,
her eyes got as big as my head,
but,
and I don't know what she ultimately decided,
but she's 24 now and we talked,
I just talked to her yesterday.
We talk all the time.
We talk about her sex life,
we talk about her job,
we talk about her,
you know,
ideas about graduate school.
We talk about everything.
And I feel like that conversation opened this door where she knew that,
you know,
there was never going to,
I was never going to flinch.
You know,
I was never going to flinch no matter what she told me,
no matter what we talked about,
I was there.
And I just think to be able to have that relationship with your niece,
with your friend's kids,
with your own daughter,
ideally,
it's just a huge gift in this culture.
Yeah.
So you mentioned kind of off hand to talking,
talking to children in age appropriate ways about sex.
One of the things that I've learned in talking with parents is that the
definition of age appropriate varies very wildly.
Do you have any guidance on
that?
You know what I would do,
I think what I'd like to do is recommend a couple of books too because that's a
really conversation and there are really interesting books that look at it from
a,
uh,
um,
development,
developmental psychology point of view.
Um,
Debra Roffman's book talk to me first,
uh,
talks about kids from infancy to teenage years.
I mean,
you know,
upper teenagers and Alvin Nacchio,
the pizza guy has a book called for goodness sex.
And both of those books are wonderful about guiding you.
Like,
what do you tell your two year old,
you know,
what do you tell your 10 year old,
what do you tell your 12 year old?
It's really helpful from that.
But I do think that,
you know,
there is a way that we start from the get go by naming the body parts.
And I mean,
I don't know if any of you have a preschooler,
but preschoolers masturbate all the time and you know,
one way to make that,
to talk about that with them is,
you know,
to say,
Gee,
you know,
it's great.
It feels really good when you touch your Volvo.
It doesn't it,
but,
and not,
and,
um,
we don't do that at the Thanksgiving table.
We do that in private and in,
in our rooms.
And you know,
it's okay to talk about privacy,
which is not the same as secrecy,
you know,
and start building that idea of bodily integrity and,
and pleasure and having control and understanding of your body.
It's okay to say,
you know,
you don't have to hug great aunt Nancy if you don't want to.
I'm not going to make you do that because that's,
you know,
pushing you beyond a boundary and you should be able to set your boundaries,
nor are you.
Am I going to make her hug you?
And I'm just going to live with the embarrassment that great aunt Nancy thinks
I'm a really bad parent.
You know?
Um,
so even things like that that aren't necessarily,
I mean,
a lot of this is not about sex.
It's about creating an atmosphere of trust.
And it's about creating an atmosphere of ethics and values in the same way that
we do in any area of our kids' lives and the way that we want them to treat
others and in the way that we want them to expect others to treat them.
But I would recommend those two books about the actual direct specifics.
Yeah.
Um,
talk to me first by Deborah Rothman and for goodness,
sex by Alvara Nacchio,
which is v e R,
I think.
But if you look at Pizza Guy and sex,
you'll find them.
So I have a team come up there.
Ninja.
I have a really good one.
Did
Fred,
who wants to raise her children with a culturally appropriate rehearsed sexual
ethic?
They're very strong Christians.
I'm personally not,
but you know,
she's a really good friend of mine and one of her challenges is she wants to be
able to have these sorts of conversations that respect the child,
the girls as women who have these bodies but has even less resources we're
doing.
So in a way within that subculture where I think a lot of,
you know,
just the idea of saying,
Oh,
think about the relationship you're in and what you're getting out of it is not
really the conversation she wants to have.
I mean if it's the reality that's a different thing,
but it's not the example she wants to set.
So you have any advice for people coming from that perspective?
That's a very good question.
I mean,
I think that you can again talk about
ideas about bodily integrity,
about respect,
about pleasure,
about limit setting about that.
That don't necessarily mean that you have to,
you know,
go from zero to 60 what's comfortable for you?
What's valuable to you?
I mean I think you can have those same conversations regardless of when you
expect a young person.
I mean,
I don't know if what if,
what you're talking about.
One of the things that was true with
people who advocated abstinence until marriage was that again,
they were very focused on intercourse.
And what we know about that is that first of all,
it doesn't work.
Um,
those kids have sex,
have intercourse at the same rates as other people.
They do tend to have start maybe a little later,
but it's a matter of months.
They have maybe fewer partners,
but they have much higher rates of pregnancy and disease way higher rates of
disease.
Um,
we also know that they engage in other forms of sexual activity,
particularly particularly oral and anal sex at higher rates and other teenagers.
So one thing to understand for your friend would be that that's the likely
outcome.
If you take that point of view,
if you still want to take that point of view,
you better be having a whole other set of discussions about what that means and
how kids can engage in ways that would still,
where they can express affection,
where they can express sensuality that you feel jives with your values.
But it's a tough one because I mean,
essentially you're educating your children for ignorance.
You're educating your children for,
um,
risk.
You're putting your children at risk when you,
when you take that perspective.
So it's hard for me to give advice on how to do it in a healthy way.
Oh,
you have a question,
Dave,
in your book,
you mentioned something called Philip Phobia,
which is your work.
How's it relate to the subject?
So interesting.
I was talking to this girl,
you're the first person who's asked me about that.
That was such a profound experience.
I was talking to this young woman who told,
you know,
it's like really swaggery and really like,
I have sex,
like a guy by which she meant she didn't have to have any feelings,
which I'd like to question in a minute.
Um,
you know,
and she could just objective,
she objectified men,
the way men objectify women.
Um,
she would tell you,
no,
I don't want to that guy.
He's too fat and you know,
I'm not going to go with that.
You know,
she was like,
really?
Um,
like
the way I would hope a male would never treat my daughter.
That was how she was treating boys.
Um,
and she felt really good about that.
And then at the very end of the interview we talked for about two hours.
I said,
do you have anything else you want to talk about?
And she said,
feel a phobia.
And I said,
excuse me?
She said,
feel a phobia.
And I said,
I'm sorry.
I don't know what that means.
And she said,
fear of love.
I think that I have fear of love.
I would not,
I do all of this,
but I am really afraid of ever really liking somebody and getting into a
relationship with them.
And it was a really,
you know,
it was,
it was like this really deep moment.
She almost cried of,
you know,
what was she getting out of what she was doing?
She,
and what wasn't she getting?
Um,
and thinking about her,
I was,
you know,
I felt like that idea that how we should learn to,
that the progress is somehow becoming as disconnected as we can be.
You know,
getting,
getting our sexual hookups on,
on Tinder or whatever people are doing now.
Um,
that is a really low road to equality.
That's a very low road to equality and treating other people like objects has a
very low road to equality.
And it's also clear in research that one of the things that teenagers talk about
American teenagers talk about is that they do want to hear more from their
parents and that they especially wanted to hear more from their parents about
relationships and the emotional side of sex.
And that that's a part that they,
because what's happening right now is that kids are without sex education in
schools and in the face of silence from their parents,
they go to porn because there it is on the Internet.
And I don't,
you know,
I don't want to,
especially in front of you guys,
I don't want to demonize the Internet,
but you know,
one of the things it's done is allowed,
you know,
pouring into your house 24,
seven,
really easily accessible,
um,
increasingly explicit because it's competitive,
got to be increasingly competitive and kids are able to access it at ever
earlier ages.
And when you look at research on this,
there was a survey of college students,
um,
in England that showed that 60% of them said that they consult porn in part as
sex education,
even though 75% of them know that it's about as realistic as pro wrestling.
Um,
and I think it's not really where we want our kids to be getting their sex
education because it's really not,
you know,
perhaps the best image and vision of female sexuality.
And you know,
it's another performative space that presents it as m for male gratification.
And I would hear about this from girls.
They would say things to me like,
um,
oh,
often they would say,
my boyfriend wants to know why I don't make the noises like the women in porn.
And I was,
again,
I got kind of frustrated and my journalist to remove faltered.
And I said,
look,
it's a movie and a movie has to have a soundtrack.
And if it doesn't,
it's a silent movie.
So people have to make the noises so that there'll be a soundtrack on the movie
that doesn't make it real.
There are actors,
you know,
they're actors.
And that was kind of a revelation to them.
Um,
on the more extreme end of that spectrum,
uh,
we've seen a significant uptick among teenagers in anal sex.
And again,
I don't want to demonize a particular behavior,
but you know,
we're talking,
like I said,
about girls who have,
um,
uh,
never masturbated,
never had an orgasm on their own,
never had an orgasm with a partner,
can't communicate effectively with their partners.
And when you look into the research,
what comes up is that it is driven,
you know,
it's a,
it's a trend that is driven by porn that,
um,
pushed more by boys because they want not as an act of intimacy with a partner,
but as like,
you know,
part of that continuing to go in a straight line and in experience and kind of
checking it off your bucket list,
um,
that the girls report on.
Surprisingly that it hurts.
But that both this is was what was interesting to me.
Both girls and boys blamed that on the girls because they say the girls are
night,
they used the language like naive,
flawed and unable to relax.
So again,
you know,
I think it's really important to get out front and talk to kids about,
porn is vision of women is about as real as real housewives vision of marriage,
you know.
Um,
but I also started feeling,
I had this conversation with my own daughter and then like a week or two later
we were watching the movie Brooklyn.
Um,
which is a great movie,
right?
Fine movie.
Or maybe you don't like it,
I don't care.
But if we know it's some,
it's fine with me.
And there's a sex scene in that movie that is very nondescript.
You know,
it's just an absolutely garden variety,
ordinary Hollywood sex scene,
which is that the two characters,
um,
kiss for a couple of seconds,
they rip off half their clothes.
They apparently are having intercourse for approximately seven and a half
seconds and then everybody's happy and it's done.
And it suddenly occurred to me that that wasn't very realistic either and that
she is probably going to see many more thousands of times that image,
that sequence than actual porn.
And what impact does that have on her idea about what sex is supposed to be and
who it's supposed to be four and who gets to enjoy it and all of that.
So I said,
you know,
honey,
okay.
You know how in a movie when somebody takes a cab ride,
okay,
they opened the door and get into the cab and then you see them open the door
and get out of the cabinet,
their destination.
But you don't see the whole cab ride because that would be like the whole movie
and it would be boring.
Similarly,
when we see sex in movies and on TV and ads and,
and all these places,
or in videos or whatever you're doing watching,
we don't see what really happens.
Hollywood has a series of symbols which are,
you know,
kind of outdated on what sex is,
and they throw those up and that is supposed to signal to us that sex has
happened,
but it doesn't actually tell us anything about what real sex is or the
experience of sex.
And I felt like that was at least as important for kids to understand,
as you know,
talking to them about porn.
So
a little ways from field of phobia,
but there you go.
All right.
Thank you very much.
I'm like,
okay,
thanks.
[inaudible].